tu n'es pas la seule personnalité à
t'appeler et à porter le prénom qui rit
hamon va jouer à thierry beccaro ou
l'autre thierry d'accord je vous propose
des situations où on me dit c'est
thierry beccaro l'autre thierry thierry
beccaro ou l'autre thierry à titiller
les fesses d'un ourson en pleine
émission
oui c'est toi oui ah oui peut-être
ouais ouais c'était dans quelle mission
c'était non matin bonheur c'est pas vrai
ah oui je présentais un ours en peluche
tampon sous la douche regardez ça c'est
plus chaud c'est le change tout le monde
parce que les des choses que vous ne
savez pas ce que c'est vrai qu'il vous
tient chaud ça moi il faut le brancher
et je voulais vous montrer samedi qu'il
faut le brancher là comme ça il ya une
petite prise ici il faut mettre la prise
ici est sale chauffe et sa mue en forme
qu'il y ait quelque chose
j'ai manqué un petit pluchon qui
sommeille en toi
non c'est mignon mais thierry je n'ai
jamais revu ça non plus ça fait une
banque de données incroyable c'est
normal on est pas mal
ah ouais faut tirer toujours souriant
samatar monnaie message est toujours mis
un point d'honneur à voilà à apporter du
plaisir aux gens de voilà parce que vous
faites vous c'est ce qu'on essaye puis
je suçais je te le dis une fois
motus a failli s'arrêter il ya eu 1 tu
sais c'est vrai es-tu avaient
confectionné tu avais fait confectionner
un un tee shirt avec le faux choix juste
et bien sûr à tenter sa chance je n'ai
jamais que je rêvais de participer à moi
tu sais j'ai des bons souvenirs avec toi
ah on a des bons souvenirs on va les
revoir et bien l'occuper de moi ah ouais
on était bien aller thierry beccaro
l'autre thierry s'est embrouillé avec un
de ses collègues pensant que les micros
étaient coupées ah oui l'autre thierry
gautier rolland roland bras insurgés il
s'est embrouillé avec jean michel larqué
pendant la mi temps de la finale brésil
allemagne en 2002 écoutez c'est un
enregistrement
c'est très bon vous avez réglé ses
problèmes de place non alors attends
avait appelé xishun mayol bâtard les
voeux les places ne sont pas lui qui rit
non mais d'accord bon mais qu'il ne
raconte pas des conneries ce que ça je
ne mets pas paradis pas de conneries non
plus dis pas de conneries qu'ils riaient
cpc placeront pas va pas me donner des
leçons à ses plats sautés rien si tu as
raison moi je te dis que ces plats sont
pas lui et bah elles sont pas toi non
plus et ben non non oui oui oui mais je
les avais je savais comment des d'abord
passer l'écueil non bâtard ésotérique
est ce congrès vise notamment à tord à
200% excusez moi si je prend la défense
de laurent mais non mais je me branle
que tu prennes je suis drôle de tous moi
je suis loin de tout mais s'il faut
régler ce problème le réglera j'en ai
rien à te dit tu vas parle de notre
temps à parler sur une autre auto alors
on attend son blog
non non c'est toi tu te mêles de quoi je
me mêle de ce qui me regarde et non tu
te mêles de tes oignons ça ne veut rien
à voir avec toi tu t'occupes de tes
fesses et et jean toi
[Applaudissements]
c'est énorme ça c'est énorme et je vais
à écouter les embrouilles de télé
réalité quand même vocabulaire mais ça
bonhomme alors les chéris tirer mais
carole autres thierry s'est retrouvé
complètement ivre sur un plateau de télé
ah non l'autre tiers annoncent hardy
sont alors dispersés par des chaussées
l'hermine tu sais qui pervertissent
ardisson anissa bienvenus l'ermite me
laisse à regarder merci des vieux cette
jeune femme elle est allée très
distinguée process voir arriver dans sa
vie alors qu'est ce que c'est simple et
[Musique]
c'est un playboy c'est un playboy qui à
la suite d'un pari va l'époque comme
j'ai pensé avant
arrêté en faisait
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et on évoque qui nous a quittés dernière
voilà sérieuse épine exceptionnelle à
l'écrire et bekar ou l'autre thierry a
joué son propre rôle dans une série sur
canal + rebecca romero c beccaro nous
attirer ou pas ouais ouais je dis bravo
c'était en 2015 dans la série ma pire
angoisse avec romain lancry sont en
hausse
et apparemment vous est la source de
tous les problèmes du personnage
regardez ça c'est très drôle c'est super
[Musique]
on a
mais c'est quoi ce délire c'est qui ce
mec a eu d'accord ce [ __ ] de
cauchemars récurrents
bon bah je vais me laisser tomber et je
me réveillais je vais pas te tuer il
pourra vous poursuivez alors je vais à
nîmes ce licra je vais t'aider à
résoudre des problèmes les problèmes gvg
pas de problème bah oui derrière cette
porte suffit d'ouvrir et bien bonjour je
vous propose aujourd'hui d'accueillir
romain qui va tenter d'atteindre la
super party ça va romain pourrait
redécouvrir votre grille quoi c'est
thierry beccaro la source de tous mes
problèmes
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est sympa ça que j'ai toujours pris
beaucoup de plaisir à faire des parodies
comme ça de motus sur les fait pas mal
je sais tu disais toujours oui quand on
voulait faire un trou et oui à condition
que ce soit marembert sur l'impression
qu'on qu' il ya de la dérision et
thierry beccaro l'autre tiéné a prouvé
en direct qu'il avait un problème
d'audition en plus d'en avoir rien à
cirer de son collègue
grâce à sa loterie series tels thierry
les six qu'elle tient la série a redit
sa piscine ont été déroutés dans la
séquence à blanchir et bensaïd hamel
combat 3d - intitulé thierry beccaro
l'autre tiré à prouver en direct qu'il
avait un problème d'audition en plus de
n'avoir rien à cirer de son collègue
thierry bensari moreau thierry moreau
est ce que tu te rappelles de sas était
sur le plateau de tpm ptt invités lolo
ce soir là et qui rime bourreau et
thorzain déni de ouf
face à jean michel mr regarder ça
j'aurais pleuré de rire à l'époque
regarder
nous attaquer pour passer dans l'autre
camp cyril vous avez kippour place notre
message appelait qu'il en fasse mal
autres commissaires vous explique rémi
saria l'autre on vous appelez qui pour
pasqua l'autre qu'on tue à petit feu sur
les faux at on dit ça il s'en fout
totalement de ce que lui jean michel
berrit n'existe pas pour lui qui rit
mais caron l'autre thierry a failli se
faire entarté en plein direct on en a
parlé tout à l'heure c'est bien sûr
tirer beccaro gras l'ombre c'était assez
sage inattendu mais gérer j'ai réagi
plus tôt
ça va encore de faire fermeture va
frémir la laure heitz va très bien
c'était très violent
c'était en 97 regardez là c'était bat
thierry mais caron professeur des écoles
et ensuite on s'est fait sauter avec de
l'huile d'olive de l'ail des piments
d'espelette
[Musique]
attendez attendez doucement doucement
attendez attendez viens avec moi tu peux
m'expliquer ce que tu as voulu faire
exactement là une entarteur
et pour quelle raison je sais pas qu'on
rigolait est ce que tu crois que là tu
fais rire non je me suis planté là bas
plan b est ce que tu es ce que tu crois
que là tu as muse il faut prendre la
responsabilité de ses actes est ce que
vous trouvez qu'il est drôle
voilà effectivement la france entière
était mort de rire
c'est énorme c'est génial je pense que
la caméra est sur moi suivi regrette
qu'on ne rit mais franchement je ne sais
pas qui a fait ça mais ils sont soit et
son coup on aurait dit que sur toi cet
élément exceptionnel un mec est en train
de faire du surf ça c'est parce que tu
es sur france 3 c'est écoute moi bien au
récit mais surtout ils ont rajouté du
son nous arrive ici il ya le directeur
ibrahim il descend son bureau ils le
savent et en plus c'est super frustrant
pour voir moi je pense que l'agresseur
fait jeter charles bronson menacé final
c'est régis la jouette cadre est grosse
a comme [ __ ] et la tam est génial ce
que tu as dit et tu trouves ça m'arrange
est ce que c'est ce que ça veut dire